تحذر العديد من المنظمه الدوليه ومراكز
الدراسات من مخاطر الارتفاع المستمر في
درجات الحراره على الاقتصاد العالمي وبات
ينظر اليها على انها واحده من الكوارث
الكبرى بما تسببه من وفيات وحرائق وتدبير
واسع لقطاعات اقتصاديه عديده ويقول تقرير
لمؤسسه سويسري لاعاده التامين ان اجماليه
انتاج الاقتصاد العالمي قد يخسر 18% بحلول
عام 2050 بسبب التغيرات المناخيه اذا لم
يتم اخذ الاجراءات اللازمه كما اظهرت
الدراسات حديثه ان الحراره الشديده قد
تكلف انتاجيه الولايات المتحده نحو 100
مليار دولار سنويا من خساره الانتاجيه
وحدها وقد تستنزف سدس النشاط الاقتصادي
العالمي بحلول عام 2100 ومن المتوقع ان
تؤدي زياده الاجهاد الحراري الناتج عن
الاحترار العالمي الى خسائر عالميه في
الانتاجيه تعادل 80 مليون وظيفه بدوام في
عام 2030 وفقا لتقرير جديد صادرا عن منظمه
العمل الدولي كما ستؤدي الحراره الشديده
الى تقويض نظم الزراعه وثروه الحيوانيه
بشكل متزايد وبحسب تقرير لمنظمه العمل
الدوليه فان الخسائر الاقتصاديه المتعلقه
بالاجهاد الحراري سترتفع من 280 مليار
دولار في عام
1995 الى التريليونين و400 مليار دولار في
عام 2030 مع تكبد البلدان منخفضه الدخل
النصيب الاكبر من الخسائر وفي بلد
كاليونان حيث تمثل السياحه 17% من الناتج
القومي الاجمالي للبلاد ادت الحرائق التي
اجتاحت جزيره رودس الى اجلاء الالاف من
السياح وتسببت في خسائر مباشره كبيره
للكثير من الفنادق والمنتجعات السياحيه
وتضطر المواقع السياحيه الشهيره في
اليونان وغيرها لاجراء تعديلات بسبب الحر
الشديد فقد اضطرت دول مثل اسبانيا
وايطاليا الى اجراءات لتقليل اضرار الحر
على القطاعات الحيويه وبحسب جمعيه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه للسفر التي تتخذ من
بروكس المقرا لها فان عدد السياح
الاوروبيين الذين يخططون للسفر الى
الوجهات البحريه في المتوسط خلال الصيف
والخريف تراجع بنسبه 10% مقارنه بالفتره
ذاتيه من العام الماضي